this is the face of evil a jealous loner
who bludgeoned then buried his innocent
victims under his house in the Hope
they'd never be found
she is very much missed by the family
penalyn bark was an adoring mum to
two-year-old jelica both gone their loss
incomprehensible to relatives in the
Philippines brutal deaths that haunt a
sister searching for answers her words
translated by a friend
so shallow is saying that in the last
two years it's been very difficult
coping
[Music]
and traumatized by the fact that they
couldn't understand why it happened
moved to this area near Bristol in 2019
years later she met Andrew Ennis online
he promised her work at the same time he
was making internet searches for
sedatives and underfloor storage before
driving to their home here on the 18th
of February 2021 they were reported
missing officially a few weeks later as
concern grew and suspicion mounted
detectives here in this community
launched a major investigation which
would eventually lead them to a very
Grim Discovery 450 miles away in Dundee
this journey to Scotland would
eventually lead to his demise his car
tracked the whole way his victims were
Charmed into sightseeing and Dundee
haunting images taken by the man who
hours later described getting
apocalyptically angry here he is buying
a hammer the same weapon he would use to
inflict unimaginable horror repeatedly
striking benalin over the head while
also stabbing her then he suffocated and
strangled jelica just two years old
before wrapping both their bodies in
bags and burying them in concrete deep
beneath his kitchen floor
Ed himself pity to the private that he's
shown is unimaginable do you think
you'll ever be able to forgive Andrew
Ennis after this
embarrassed and will not be able to come
out Innis is also a child rapist abusing
another girl for weeks in his living
room
over a dangerous murderer at the center
of one of the most harrowing cases this
country has ever seen Connor Gillis Sky
News